hey 42 here more than 2,500 left-handed
people are killed each year whilst using
equipment designed for right-handed
people the most dangerous of which is
the power saw life sure can be hard for
a lefty the word right is synonymous
with the word correct whereas left comes
from Old English where it meant sinister
and evil in Old England left handedness
was actually believed to have come from
the devil
so in left handedness is such a
disadvantage then why are between 10 and
12 percent of the population still
left-handed after all evolution
typically weeds out imperfections within
a species but scientists have found
evidence that is far back as 500,000
years ago 10% of humans were left-handed
it's always been this way
so there must still be some advantage to
being left-handed even in the modern
world so what is it let's find out
contrary to some Phoebe's left-handed
this is not learnt as a child it's not
simply a matter of which hand the child
chooses to write with from an early age
if this were true the numbers will be
closer to 50/50 for left and
right-handedness but only 10% of the
population is left-handed in fact we can
actually tell if a baby is going to be
left or right-handed when they're only a
couple of months old when you place a
baby on its tummy
babies who will grow up to be
left-handed will typically turn their
heads to the left
whereas right-handers will do the
opposite now before you go haphazardly
flipping over babies to try this out for
yourself you should know it's not an
entirely accurate way to tell but
research has shown there's a strong
correlation there so if we don't learn
left handedness then where does it come
from
statistics suggests we're born with it
it's in our genes to right-handed
parents have a nine percent chance to
give birth to a left-handed child when
one parent is left-handed that rises to
19 percent and when both parents are
left-handed the chance is 26 percent
these statistics suggests that
handedness is at least somewhat
hereditary what left handedness is
highly unusual because it's not simply
caused by dominant and recessive genes
about 90% of people are right-handed
suggesting that right handedness is an
extremely dominant trait based on what
we know about genetics a gene that is so
fiercely dominant in this case right
handedness would have forced a recessive
gene left handedness out of the gene
pool altogether a long long time ago in
theory we shouldn't have left-handed
people anymore yet we still do and the
percentage of people that are born
left-handed isn't decreasing like it
theoretically should do in fact it has
stayed exactly the same for thousands of
years
this suggests that handedness isn't
caused by a simple case of dominant
versus recessive genes it's considerably
more complex than that it's likely to be
caused by a whole mix of different genes
or perhaps something completely
different altogether the truth is that
why some people prefer one hand over the
other is still a bit of a mystery
there is one theory however that is the
most commonly accepted answer to this
perennial question researchers think
handedness is actually caused by
something called brain lateralization
our brains are divided into two
hemispheres left and right for the sake
of efficiency our brains like to use
different regions for different tasks
two of the most energy intensive
activities that humans do are language
and using our fine motor skills so our
brain clusters the control of those
activities into one side of our brain
rather than having it spread out all
over the damn place this makes those
tasks more energy efficient most
people's language and fine motor skills
are controlled by the left hemisphere of
their brain and each hemisphere
generally controls the opposite side of
the body so it makes sense that most
people would be right-handed because in
most people the majority of the
processing which controls the movement
of muscles is done in the left
hemisphere of their brain which is the
hemisphere of the brain that controls
the right side of the body
in fact in 90% of right-handed
individuals they use the left hemisphere
of their brain to control language and
fine motor skills whereas a considerably
lower 61% of left-handers control these
skills using the left side of their
brain in most animals the hemispheres of
their brain divide the processing of
tasks equally those same animals have no
hand preference whereas human brains
tend to specialized functions to either
one side of the brain or the other and
consequently we also favor a particular
hand this strong correlation has led
biologists to think that brain
lateralization is closely linked to
handedness left hemisphere brain
lateralization is a common trend amongst
left-handers but it doesn't fully
explain why people are left handed to
begin with after all 61% of left-handers
still use the left hemisphere of their
brain the same side that right handers
use researchers at Pennsylvania State
University
leave handedness is caused by genes
their fear is that there are two
distinct alleles of a gene which cause
handedness an allele is a variation of a
gene one of those alleles is known as
the D gene which done for dextral
meaning right the other allele is called
the C gene which stands for chance the D
gene is the most common in the human
gene pool and when it is present the
person will always be right-handed you
made therefore think that the presence
of the significantly less common c gene
will mean the person is left-handed but
it's known as the chance gene because
when it's present the hand preference of
the person will be random there will be
a 50/50 chance of the person being left
or right-handed
this means that there's a third class of
handedness there's a small percentage of
people who have some degree of
ambidexterity
being ambidextrous means one is equally
as proficient with both hands
since genes come in pairs every human
has one of three combinations of the
aforementioned D and C genes the first
combination is d d meaning the person
has a strong right-handed byers the
second combination is CC meaning there's
a straight-up 50-50 chance the person
will be either left or right-handed but
the third combination is quite unusual
the third possibility is DC meaning they
have one of each gene variation people
have both Adi right-handed and the C
chance gene are usually most proficient
with their right hand but they are also
perfectly capable using their left hand
people who have a DC gene combination
are somewhere in the spectrum of being
semi ambidextrous two fully ambidextrous
such people make up only 1% of the
population so if you are one of the 1%
that can adequately use both hands well
done you have a very rare set of genes
but if you are left-handed it's not all
bad news there's numerous benefits to
being a lefty lefties are sought-after
in competitive sports since most players
are right-handed Allah
deikun surprise and unnerve their
opponent gaining the advantage because
most players are used to fighting
right-handed opponents not left-handers
sportswear left-handers have such an
advantage include tennis baseball and
boxing to name but a few
also scientists aren't quite sure why
but lefties are considerably more likely
to be a genius than righties
for example 20% of Mensa members are
left-handed which is a
disproportionately large amount when you
consider that only 10% of the population
are left-handed
some believe lefties are more
intelligent because throughout their
life they've been forced to use and
workout both sides of their brain
instead of just the one side also an
unusually high percentage of u.s.
presidents have been left-handed too
including Barack Obama Bill Clinton
George HW Bush and Ronald Reagan there
are endless benefits to being a lefty so
even if the word left is synonymous with
being evil don't worry next time your
friend teases you for being a lefty just
remind them that you're considerably
more likely to be accepted into Mensa
and you stand there much better chance
than they do at becoming presidents
thank to the view subscribe for more 42